(audience cheering)
- Oh my god.
- It's crazy.
- I was like, I had no idea.
I've never met you in person.
I was like, "You are tall."
- Can I just start by saying,
I'm fanning out a little bit.
- Oh my gosh, I am too.
Of you and your height.
(everyone laughing)
- You're such a big, big hit in my house.
My wife and daughter in particular,
are huge fans of yours, so.
- They have great taste.
- They do.
(audience applauding)
Of course they, well-
- Well, thank you.
- I mean, yes.
- That's so nice.
That's so nice. I'm a huge
fan, I've been so excited.
I literally am gonna be talking
about this all day, though.
I had no idea you were that tall.
And I was like, "Oh my god."
And I'm wearing heels, so whatever.
But happy belated birthday.
- Well, thank you.
- A few weeks ago,
you had a huge birthday.
It's a big birthday.
- You know, Kelly. I
don't count them anymore.
- You don't?
- No. I mean, I feel blessed
to have another day of life for sure, but-
- That's why I do count them.
Not everybody gets them.
- We're not gonna talk numbers.
- Oh, no, you don't have to.
But I just, not everybody gets those,
you know, that many years.
So it is a blessing.
- It is true.
- Yeah, and it's good to celebrate.
I'm opposite. I don't care about age.
I don't really care.
- Age is a funny thing.
You know, what I find is that,
my god, as I've gotten older,
I just get more sensitive, like-
- Oh, yeah. I think-
- I'll watch your show,
your other show,
I'll watch you on "The Voice"
and I'll watch a young singer
who aspires to be a
superstar like you and-
- [Kelly] Oh, the stories get you.
- And, the stories for sure,
but the song itself will move me to tears.
And my son, who's 17 and kinda tough,
looks over at me and goes,
"Dad, what-"
- "What are you doing?"
- "Why are you crying?
Like, why are you crying?"
(Kelly laughing)
I said, "Buddy, I cry
at coffee commercials.
Like, I don't know why I'm crying."
As I've gotten older,
I don't know what's going on with me,
but, I don't know.
Maybe it's that we're all-
- That's amazing. I feel like-
- Facing mortality now.
I don't know what it is.
- I don't know, but I also feel like,
men, I think you've,
I think you're, especially my generation,
your generation like,
they were taught they weren't
allowed to be emotional.
You were supposed to be
strong or whatever growing up?
And I feel like,
I don't know, over the course of time
I think each (indistinct)
and your just like,
whatever it's touching.
I'm gonna let it out.
I'm gonna cry.
- Yeah, that's not the lesson
I teach in my household.
(Kelly laughing)
You're free and welcome
to cry at any moment.
- Yeah, I know, but we're a different,
I'm teaching my children
differently, as well,
but I just meant from our
generation it was always like,
I'm from the South.
Like, it was like, don't show emotion.
- Oh, of course.
- That is weak.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Whatever.
Well, with two kids at home,
do you and your wife ever
get away by yourself?
- You know, it's rare,
but we thankfully had an
opportunity to get away,
just the two of us.
Whenever we do go on vacation,
it's always with the kids.
But we got an opportunity
head off to Hawaii,
and it was just a couple
days after Thanksgiving,
but it wasn't without a little
bit of a hiccup because,
you know, we flew in from the East Coast
and we had a connecting flight in Phoenix
before we went on to the Big Island.
But as we were coming into Phoenix,
the flight attendant comes up
to me and my wife and says,
"Um, is your final destination Kona?"
And we said, "Yeah, it
is. We're really excited."
And she goes, "Have you seen this?"
And she showed me-
- [Kelly] The volcano, yeah.
(Kelly laughing)
- The CNN report that
the Mauna Loa Volcano
was erupting for the
first time in 40 years.
- [Kelly] And you haven't been on like,
a date or vacation-
- No! In like eight years.
- [Kelly] And you're like, "What?" Yeah.
- So we immediately
called the travel agent.
She said, "I haven't even heard of it,
but I think it's fine. You
should should head on."
So we get there, and of course
we check into the hotel,
and behind the hotel is a red sky.
Mind you, it's 10 o'clock at night.
But it looked like the sun was rising.
It wasn't the sun, it
was the active volcano.
- Were you not nervous about landing
in a place where that's happening?
- You know, my wife said,
"Let's be a little more
optimistic about it.
Maybe it's God's way of
just showing us fireworks
for our arrival."
- Oh my god, an optimist.
You married a glass
half full. That's nice.
I would've been like, mm-
- She's gonna call me on that.
- Let's go to Cabo.
- She didn't actually say that.
- Yeah.
- I thought it.
- Yeah. I was like, wait, no.
You and your wife just celebrated,
is it the 20th anniversary?
- Yes.
- That's incredible.
(audience cheering)
I think that it's hard.
It can be hard like
growing, you know, together
in a marriage. That's incredible.
- You know, relationships,
marriages can be hard.
Ours is not. You know-
- Rub it in, yeah.
- Life is hard.
- Kidding.
- But what should be easy is
a kind of a loving harmony
with your spouse.
Of course, you're always
gonna have differences
of opinion or whatever,
but if the relationship is
based on love, mutual respect
and a great liking for one another,
and a little bit of heat,
which also-
- Hey!
- Always goes a long way.
- Yeah.
- Then you can take on life together.
Life is filled with challenges
and we certainly all have faced ours,
but she's my best friend.
- I was gonna say, it's probably-
- She makes me laugh.
- She's your best friend.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know, she was a working actor
when we met and got together
and she put all of that on
hold to raise my two children.
I have a daughter, Sophia, who's 20,
who's a child with special needs
and who will spend her life with us.
And so it was a, some
might consider a big ask
for my wife to put her art on hold,
but she doesn't see it that way at all.
Like, our number one priority as parents
is to love and nurture our children
and make sure they have an
opportunity to succeed in life.
- You met a great one.
(audience cheering)
So the new show looks great.
It's called "Poker Face."
So tell us what it's about.
- "Poker Face" is the brainchild
of Ryan Johnson and Natasha Lyonne.
Two dear friends who got together
and came up with this show
that really is a kind of a
nod to the murder mystery
from the seventies.
The premise of the show is a young woman
by the name of Charlie Cale,
who has this innate
ability to be able to tell
when someone is lying.
But for her, that's not the fun.
The fun is to discover
why a person is lying.
But wherever she goes, dead
people seem to show up.
And so her, you know,
she's the kind of person
who likes to use that skill
to help people who are down on their luck.
So it's not really a murder mystery show
as much as it it is a how to catch them.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So the pilot finds her as a
cocktail waitress at a casino.
We discover very early that someone dies
and she goes about the rest
of the episode discovering
who's responsible and why.
- Man, are you good at
telling if someone's lying?
I'm really not.
- I think I have a
pretty good BS detector.
- [Kelly] You do?
- But, but you know,
the funny thing is-
- Can you teach that?
- Well, we all lie a little
bit, don't we? I mean-
- One hundred percent. I lie
to my children all the time.
I love you. But yeah.
- I mean, it's bad-
- I tell them things
are closed all the time.
- It's bad business to lie-
- Totally.
- But we all do.
And usually over the most
mundane, like ridiculous things.
There's always-
- I don't wanna go
to Chuck E. Cheese right now. Yeah.
- "Honey, I'm five minutes away,"
when you haven't left the,
whatever the location is.
- One hundred percent.
- That's me. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- What's cool about this particular show
is it's a 10 part limited series.
And other than the pilot
and the final episode,
is you can, you can watch
out of sequence episode four,
go to episode seven, go
back to episode three,
because each one hour of the episode
is its own kind of standalone movie.
Charlie Cale, Natasha's
character, solving a murder.
And because it's Ryan
Johnson, who's, you know,
out there right now with "Glass Onion."
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- You know, it's gonna be,
it'll have shocking violence,
it'll have a lot of humor,
and it'll have, you know, you
guessing all along the way
about how the whole
thing's gonna be solved.
- I love that.
Great storytelling.
- Amazing storytelling.
- That must be fun to
be on a set like that.
- And Natasha, have you ever
had Natasha on as a guest?
- No, I love her.
- She's a writer and director as well,
and she actually writes and
directs one of the episodes-
- Brilliant.
- Throughout the season.
But it's her personality.
It's her energy. What she
brings to the character,
it makes it totally unique.
I mean, the architecture of the show,
it's a genre we're all very familiar with
and it's very, very popular, you know-
- But it's cool to have
a different spin on it.
- It's her nature that
really makes it compelling.
- Yeah. I have to ask you this,
because this is the craziest
thing I've ever heard.
Literally, and I've been
doing this four seasons.
Is it true that your mom
had you live on Alcatraz a
little bit when you're a child?
Like what's that story?
- Yeah. You know, I was born
and raised in San Francisco.
And briefly in 1969,
a group of young Native American students
from San Francisco State decided
to take over Alcatraz Island
as kind of a political statement.
As most of you know,
Alcatraz was a federal
penitentiary up until 1962,
and it remained out of
operation until 1969.
And these young students were smart enough
to cite an old treaty
from the 1800s that cited
any government held land
that was not being used
reverts back to the sovereignty
of native people.
So it was a political gesture
that was national news,
international news for that matter,
and my mom was a part of
the group that then settled
on the island during
the 18 month occupation.
I was five years old
and I lived in the city,
but I would say every weekend,
at least two nights a week,
we were living on the island.
- Your mom is so cool.
- That's my brother Peter,
who's a filmmaker now, and
my youngest sister, Verushka.
I was actually meant to be in
that shot, but I got bored.
(everyone laughing)
- You got bored on Alcatraz?
- I was running around the other part
of the cell blocks there.
- Yeah. I've been to Alcatraz.
That would be a scary place
kind of for a kid, or fun.
- But it wasn't scary at
all because, you know,
I think parents are different
about their responsibilities
and raising kids these days.
It wasn't that my mom
didn't care about us.
She was like, "Just go play."
And so we'd go-
- Free. Yeah.
- We'd go onto the
industrial side of the island
and you know, throw rocks
at windows and go crabbing.
You know, we'd go down on the shoreline
and look for crabs, et cetera.
But it was the ultimate
playground, really,
for me and my brother
and my three sisters.
- Yeah. It's just a really cool thing too,
to introduce something that's important
and show your kids to
think outside of yourself
at such young ages. That's cool.
- Yeah. You know, this
was in the aftermath
of my mom getting a
divorce from my father.
And she was an immigrant.
She came from Lima, Peru at the age of 14.
And so I think she felt
a little left untethered
and so when she found
this native community
and it embraced her fully,
she found, in a way, her
own sense of identity.
And it's an identity, a native identity
that she left us as a legacy.
You know, she actually called
the young Mohawk leader,
Richard Oakes, who was the
leader of the young student group
that took over the island,
and got him on the phone when he was
on the local (indistinct) PBS channel.
And she said, "I'm Native
American from South America.
Does that count?"
And he said, "Indians of
all tribes come down."
And she said it's the first time
that she was in the country
that she felt like she belonged.
But what's unusual is this
habit we have had historically
of trying to put everyone
in a specific box.
This is what you are,
and that's your identity.
Leave the identifying to the individual.
It's something I continue to
hand down to my own children.
- That's cool. You had a rad mama.
(audience applauding)
- And listen, she's still doing the do.
I mean, my mother is, she's
the center of the universe
for all of us.
- That's so cool. Not everybody
gets that kind of family.
That's kind of magical.
- That's true.
And that's the American story.
I mean, an immigrant
comes to this country.
She has children.
- Absolutely.
- And she ends up finding
a way to contribute.